[Music]
we got some questions from social media
you can follow the minimalists on tiktok
instagram facebook and twitter at the
minimalist you can follow bex at
wellness on instagram and i think that's
just about it instagram minimal wellness
you can find her there we have a
question from amelia on instagram just a
heads up from the uk the name of your
first patreon deal is an ableist slur
now that you know it's offensive are you
going to change it
[Laughter]
oh interesting let's talk about this
okay
so i understand where you are coming
from amelia but we probably need to talk
about a a few things here
first off you're offended and it's not
my job to unoffend you
in fact let me be honest with you let me
tell you a little secret
i can't offend you i do not have the
power to offend you and if you're
listening to this you're watching this i
don't have the power to offend you
either now you can
say you're offended by something that i
say some of the tk says something that
bex
says but we don't actually have that
power to offend you you offend yourself
and here's what i'll say about we call
all of our listeners simpletons right
now that is not a ableist slur
i want to be clear about it what the
difference between a a denotation and a
connotation right a denotation is what a
word means well
a simpleton is a foolish or gullible
person that's the definition of a
simpleton i happen to be both we ryan
and i picked simpletons a long time ago
because he was the foolish one i was the
gullible one
and uh
we picked simpleton to reclaim
a word
that had a pejorative meaning to it not
an ableist slur but it had a pejorative
meaning
but why did we do that let's talk about
why someone might reappropriate a word
that otherwise
is considered a slur
anybody know of any words that i don't
know
people have used the slurs and then some
group of people reappropriates that word
in a way that makes them feel connected
with other people
well i do there's quite a few but one
for us was simpleton
because
well it's a triple entendre we're simple
and there's a ton of us now simple ton a
ton of simple people but also what does
it show
ryan and i don't take ourselves very
seriously
okay
we call our listeners simpletons because
by the way they voted on it we asked all
of our listeners hey
we're thinking of what do we call our
audience are you minimizers are you
minimalists are you intentionalists are
you essentialists
what do you want to be called
minis
and they all voted overwhelmingly
thousands of people voted for
simpleton and so he said hey this group
of people
we're all acknowledging that we don't
take ourselves seriously we have to be
able to talk about some things
in a serious
manner
but through
levity
because it's going to crush me if i have
to pretend that all this materialism
stuff which is ruining a lot of lives if
i have to take it so seriously like i'm
a calculus textbook
i'm not going to be able to communicate
with people in a way
now can that word be used as a slur sure
that's what connotation means
a
i i don't use it that way and amelia i
hope you are not using the word that way
as an ableist slur either right
but there are other words
bex and i used to live over here in boys
town right
and the word gay
it's in the flintstones theme song it
means happy right but you can also use
it as a pejorative oh that's gay
okay
well
how are you using the word
am i ever using the word simpleton to
make fun of someone no of course not
i would never
use that in a derogatory way what we've
done is we've reclaimed the word in a
way that allows us to have
fun to be part of an in-group
yeah you know
it's interesting because this this
brings up
uh so many issues for one it brings up
the issue of
being concerned with
how i sound when i say it
versus being concerned with what i am
intending to convey
and
if the problem is with how i sound when
i say it then we can have a conversation
about my semantics should i use
different language or whatever it may be
to express myself or is the conversation
about what i intend to mean and we do
live in a world now
where you will get checked very fast at
the level of how you sound when you say
something without any examination being
you know performed with regards to what
do you intend to convey and i think this
is tragic and i do not accuse
the questioner of doing this but i think
as a broader phenomenon it's tragic when
when this particular thing i'm
describing happens because what happens
a lot especially online
is
someone will say something and mean
something benevolent
and another person will call them on it
um over the fact that they said it in a
way that sounded bad
and now you have someone who instead of
being educated or instead of you know
being engaged intelligently they're
they're being buried they're being piled
on top of one another with criticism and
so on so yeah i think that's an
important distinction another thing too
is
you know they're kind of like two levels
of offensiveness with words like when
you talk about i don't have the power to
offend you i i know exactly what you're
saying right at the end of the day
we are responsible for how we process
our own thoughts and feelings and we do
have the power to neutralize other
people's use of language even when they
do intend to offend us you know uh the
the black comedian paul mooney used to
say i say the n word a thousand times a
day it makes my teeth white he took that
word
and and when he lived at a time when
people would use it to hurt him he
snatched it away from them and say i use
it more than you and in a way that makes
me and my people laugh right and so
that is a possibility
at the same time
as an educator as a mentor as an uncle
if i'm talking to
my white god son if i'm talking to
my some of my white nieces and nephews
and if i were to hear them say the
n-word
i wouldn't cancel them i wouldn't stop
loving them
but i would seek to educate them on the
history of that word and the power that
it has to affect someone else and if
they were to say to me hey look i ain't
got the power to offend other people
other people are responsible for how
they process their feelings and emotions
the first thing i would say is like man
like for my nephew or niece at your age
for you to be able to say that first of
all that's profound so give me a pound
however
there's more to the story than that
right and i would try to educate them on
communicating in a way
that is least likely to produce offense
but then you bring up the other issue
which is for every slur for every
negative word like the n word like the b
word
there is a demographic of people who
reclaim the power of an offensive term
and use it internally you can walk into
a group of females and you'll hear
ladies say to each other what's up
b-word you'll walk into a room full of
black dudes and i'll be like what's up
my n-word and for that crowd it's a term
of endearment but it's still possible
for people outside of that crowd to be
offended by the fact that it is used at
all right it's possible for a guy to be
like well what are these women doing
calling each other that word it's
possible for a white person to be like
no nobody should use the n-word it's an
ugly word even though people in those
demographics use it and so a big part of
discussions like this is number one
making the distinction between
what you intend to convey versus merely
judging you on how you sound when you
say it but also asking who is the
audience here
who is the audience are you speaking as
part of a shared community
which has a shared understanding or are
you speaking to a broader world that
understands the word in a particular way
and i think that's critical for
navigating things like this and so i
understand what you're saying i was
curious because i hadn't even
i wouldn't have imagined that question
you know and
to hear you break down what simpletons
means why you chose it how much the
community loves it and how they chose it
it makes a lot of sense i guess my
question for you now is what happens if
the community says hey
[Music]
now that we think about it we prefer
minimizers instead would you change it
then
i would certainly consider it especially
with our you know private podcast
audience they're the ones who who voted
on it so yeah let us know in the
comments we're happy to uh to take that
under advisory yeah because i'm always
listening but just because someone has
an opinion about something doesn't mean
that it changes what the truth is about
the way that it's been used did you
enjoy this standalone patreon highlight
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
slash the minimalists or click the link
in the description your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
percent advertisement free